Anthony it's lovely to see you here
today collector mania I've been enjoying
the weekends I've been having a great
weekend you know I mean it's just a
wonderful turnout
you know so many great people great
costumes and and yeah the environments
just been been really lovely yeah of
course you got to ask you about Gotham
this is a character Victor who is known
in the comic books how do you feel he
differs on the show compares the comic
books and how have you feel you've
developed him differently well I mean of
course there's going to be there's going
to be similarities and differences
between the the comic books and the show
I mean you know the show does a great
job of giving me creative license in
order to play around I've definitely
taken a lot of a lot of kind of you know
stimulus and have done a lot of research
from the comic books but um it's it's
really the best when you get to put your
own spin on it
you know so I feel like I've really
tried to do that and make it my own
what's been your favorite part of
shooting this season uh probably I mean
there are so many aspects to it that
it's just been so much fun I mean just
the costumes and the sets and you know
just diving into that world but I've got
to say working with all the other actors
they've just been so wonderful and and
so much fun to work with I mean you know
it's just excellent chemistry to kind of
put all these dynamic and and colorful
characters together I mean how much of a
kind of comic book family before you
took on this part and what would you
like to see brought from that world into
the TV shows world oh well you know I um
I definitely was a comic book fan I mean
I am also admitted in the midst of
serious fans that I hate I totally just
bow down to um but I but I've definitely
been a fan of it of the comic books
especially Batman and and and I think
that you know in terms of what can be
kind of taken from that world I think
that you know there's so much artistry
there's so much artistry in the comic
books and and and I think that you know
TV and film can continue to kind of take
from from the amazing artists that are
creating these you know these new
you know these new incarnations of the
comic books and and really kind of you
know formatting it to filming TV
what kind of villains and other
characters you'd like to see come in
from those comic books into the world of
Gotham Oh
I mean there's that's a tough one that's
a tough one I mean there's some Scott
there's just a ton it there's there's
really too many to say but I think you
know as as the as the next season
progresses I think I think there's going
to be some really cool ones we've heard
from exec producer that Mr Freeze
Clayface and Mad Hatter are going to be
coming into season two what do you feel
about that I think that's really
exciting I mean you know that's the fun
thing is whenever you bring all these
characters in together you you know it's
really it's really fun to think about
that what kind of dynamics are all going
to create together you know what one is
going to act like with another one and
then if you put two in a room together
what's going to happen I think it's just
a really you know really really fun
thing and it's gonna be a lot of fun to
see you would you like to see your
character facing off with next time oh
that's a good question um let me see I
think was I saying before I think um it
would be it would be very interesting
for for Victor and and enigma to face
off I think you know enigma definitely
has the kind of intellectual prowess to
get into Victor's head so that would be
cool and Victor's head is not the
easiest place to navigate I mean what do
you think about the way Bruce Wayne is
developing and also how do you think
Victor would cope in the show against
the Caped Crusader if and when we get
there eventually uh well I mean I think
I think David is doing a fantastic job
as playing Bruce Wayne I think they're
really kind of fleshing out his
character and you're beginning to see
his his development into uh into you
know the Caped Crusader into Batman and
yeah I think you know he's beginning to
get stronger he's beginning to get more
courageous and
and yet and it's kind of you can see how
all these all these really unhinged
villains and Gotham were beginning to
kind of you know shape him into the into
the hero he's going to be so yeah I
think it would be it'd be really cool
for for Victor to kind of step in and
and and kind of make his mark
I suppose what do you think Victor's
response would be to meeting mr. freeze
or Clayface or Mad Hatter oh I'm sure
they would be all different responses
but um yeah I think um I don't know a
couple words come to mind he would be
very curious and yeah I mean probably
yeah probably very threatened and
curious I would say yeah now of course
you've been in the flash as well how do
you compare your character of the mist
in the flash compared to Victor well I
think yeah um yes o'connell Nimbus is a
lot more of like a thug you know he's
he's a bruiser and and it's it's a lot
of fun to play but Victor is a lot more
you know playful and colorful and
mischievous they're both totally
maniacal but yeah different you know
different flavors there what are the
chances are that we'll see you back in
the flash do you think you know I can I
cannot say I can't literally but but you
know neither of my characters are dead
and they're both at large so you'll have
to tune and find out and course we heard
recently that Robin Lord Tyler who we
know is a penguin on Gotham would very
much also like to be in the flesh so
joining you on that what do you think of
that I didn't know that but I think
Robin is so talented and I would watch
him I would watch him like fold laundry
hahaha yeah and what would you love to
see going forward in season two of
Gotham uh well you know I think um
I would love to just continue watching
the unfolding of all these brilliant
characters just kind of you know go
deeper and deeper into this world and
yeah the creators have done a really
great job introducing everything now
it's yeah it's time to just buckle your
seatbelts and enjoy the ride that's the
answer it's been lovely talking to you
thanks so much your time thank you so
much appreciated
you